merci madame la ministre la parole
l'état monsieur yves censi monsieur le
premier ministre alors que le monde
agricole s'enlise un peu plus chaque
jour dans une crise sans précédent le
début de la semaine a été marquée par
une double décharge de responsabilité du
gouvernement sur la grande distribution
et sur bruxelles
existe-t-il encore monsieur le premier
ministre une politique agricole du
gouvernement français vont multiplier
les déclarations d'intention et les
mesures d'urgence mais vous ne réglez
rien sur le long terme pour sauver
l'agriculture française le naufrage
annoncé
pour inciter les français à manger
français il faut deux piliers la qualité
d'abord ce sont les agriculteurs qui
s'en charge et ce sont les meilleurs du
monde des charges faible des prix
compétitifs
ensuite et c'est votre responsabilité
est là vous êtes les plus mauvais du
monde nos éleveurs sont pris en étau
entre des charges exorbitantes et les
centrales d'achat qui prennent jusqu'à
70% des marges les filières font face à
des abattoirs allemands qui recrutent à
500 euros par mois
les éleveurs de porcs perdre six mille
euros par semaine je rentre je rencontre
les éleveurs aveyronnais pour ta
exemplaire qui n'ont plus aucune
perspective d'avenir
alors face à l'effondrement des prix et
de manière très concrète nous souhaitons
vous répond on y est précisément sur
deux trois points premièrement sur
l'embargo russe ce qui pénalise les
produits agricoles français la france se
doit peser de tout son poids pour
demander la levée des sanctions sur la
russie où en est on deuxièmement sur les
charges
les agriculteurs qui ne peuvent pas
bénéficier du cic eux sont pris dans des
barbelés de normes et de charges il faut
les libérer
c'est ce que nous vous proposions la
semaine dernière dans une proposition de
loi des républicains vous avez appelé à
son rejet par votre majorité
alors que proposez vous maintenant
troisièmement il faut cesser de naviguer
à vue
des plans d'urgence d'urgence.ces pardon
aux autres justifications narcissique de
déplacés monsieur le foll le couple
franco-allemand doit impérativement
demander le sommet agricole européen
quand aura-t-il lieu et pour quels
objectifs
souvenez vous de cette phrase de raymond
lacombe il n'ya pas pays sans paysans
alors ne soyez pas le gouvernement qui
aura condamné les terroirs français
pourtant les plus attractifs de la
planète à devenir des jardins parole est
à monsieur stéphane le foll menez
l'agriculture
de l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt ce
président je débutais c'est donc avec
beaucoup de narcissisme que je vais
répondre à votre question vous avez
évoqué un certain nombre de choses et
vous avez rappelé la phrase de raymond
lacombe
j'aurais mais je le député comment vous
aviez des responsabilités vous ayez bien
cette phrase en tête parce que lorsque
en 2008 sous présidence de nicolas
sarkozy ont été engagées des réformes à
l'échelle européenne c'est la france qui
préside l europe
qu'est ce qui a été décidé à l'époque de
libéraliser de faire en sorte qu'on
supprime les quotas laitiers qu'on
remette en cause je le rappelle les
droits de plantation et non content de
ses choix à l'échelle européenne
vous avez fait des choix au niveau
national avec la loi de modernisation
économique qui favorise justement la
grande distribution et ses négociations
entre la grande distribution et les
industriels à monsieur le député on peut
toujours se renvoyaient de manière
facile les narcissiques
des arguments qui n'en sont pas
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
alors que l'europe après la suppression
des quotas laitiers après la suppression
des quotas laitiers voit la production
laitière européenne ne cessé d'augmenter
alors que les marchés ne sont pas au
rendez-vous à l'exportation il va
falloir revenir c'est l'objet du
mémorandum à des solutions qui
permettent de mieux réguler la
production
on va devoir refaire ce que vous avez
des faits ça déjà arrivé mais on va
continuer
sur la loi de modernisation sur la loi
de modernisation
là aussi il va falloir refaire ce que
vous aviez fait parce que c'était mal
fait nous avons donné trop de pouvoir à
ces négociations commerciales et ça pèse
aujourd'hui sur les prix agricoles
il va falloir donc indiqué dans ces
négociations tripartites le fait que les
producteurs devront être aussi partie
prenante de ces négociations
et puis je voudrais vous dire dans
l'aveyron je salue ce qui vient d'être
signé par le gros label rouge ségala
avec un contrat avec les établissements
picard contractualiser organiser
l'avenir
voilà ce qu'il faut faire pour défendre
l'agriculture et garder des paysans sur
tout d'abord merci monsieur